as we reported earlier coronavirus cases
are skyrocketing across some parts of
the nation
joining us now to discuss some of the
latest covet 19 developments
is dr tom freeman former head of the cdc
and current president
and ceo of resolve to save lives an
initiative of vital strategies
dr freeman good morning
good morning let me start with the news
this week the white house announced that
it
was having hospitals no longer report
covet information
to the cdc instead bypassing them and
going directly
to the department of health and human
services why is that alarming to you
well i think we have to see how that
plays out in the coming days and weeks
they're changing horses in midstream and
they say it's going to be better so
let's hold them to that and see if we
have
real-time information that's more
accurate than we've been getting so far
more importantly here we have one enemy
the enemy is the virus and the more
we're divided the more the virus can
conquer
we're seeing now the u.s as a laggard
we're seeing
uh deaths every 15 minutes we have five
deaths in the u.s we have over a
thousand infections every 15 minutes
we're a global outlier we've got one of
the highest death rates in the world and
it's increasing
but it's never too late to improve the
response and do better
dr fredon you and three other former
heads of the cdc
authored an op-ed in the washington post
this week
and i want to read a little of what you
referenced you wrote their sec
their sound science is being challenged
with partisan pot shots
sowing confusion and mistrust at a time
when the american people
need leadership expertise and clarity
what is the message that you want going
forward towards lawmakers and
politicians right now
we need consistent messaging we need to
follow the science follow the three w's
wear a mask correctly wash your hands
watch your distance we need consistent
messaging
masks are important contact tracing is
important
testing is important staying home is
important but no one thing is going to
control this virus
we need a science driven comprehensive
coordinated attack on the virus
that's the way our kids will be able to
go to school in the fall
we can go back to work our economy can
recover and we can save
tens of thousands of lives right now the
estimates are that we will have over 200
000
deaths in this country within the next
couple of months
this doesn't have to be it is not too
late to do a lot
better than we're doing now we need to
get on the same page track what's really
important
and work together while we stay
physically apart
very quickly before we let you go you
mentioned our children going back to
school the cdc is going to have some new
guidelines out what are some of the
things that we need to see to get our
kids back in the classroom safely
first and foremost what's going to
facilitate kids getting back to school
is less coveted in the community where
kovit is exploding in a community it's
going to be difficult if not impossible
not just to open schools but more
importantly to keep them open
if we rush in too fast as states in the
south the us did
about reopening you'll have to step back
we want schools to open and stay open
as safely as possible that means driving
the levels down in our communities
with mask wearing distancing hand
washing
bars need to be closed anywhere that
there's lots of spread of covet and
indoor dining needs to stop
so there's lots of things that we can do
and schools can prepare as well i was
gonna say the same messaging that we've
been hearing dr tom frieden thank you i
think i called you friedman
earlier we appreciate the time jeff